i think she's eyeballing me move your
melon murray so i can enchant her with a
koi wink
this can't be real
[Music]
beloved actor george segal has died
he was 87 years old siegel's wife of
over two decades
sonia siegel confirmed the news to e.t
on tuesday
sharing in a statement quote the family
is devastated to announce that this
morning
george siegel passed away due to
complications from bypass surgery
the actor's longtime friend and manager
abe
hawk also expressed his condolences
i will miss his warmth humor camaraderie
and friendship
he was a wonderful human i said you
certainly are a flop
in something i'm sorry you're
disappointed siegel found early success
in films in the mid-1960s
his biggest role came in 1966 when he
played nick
in who's afraid of virginia woolf
opposite elizabeth taylor
and richard burton everybody's a flop
your husband's a flop
i'm a flop you're all flops the part
earned him an
oscar nomination it keeps getting better
i'll tell you that
it does in the 1980s siegel transitioned
to television
securing major roles in many shows his
most notable
playing jack the sweet yet out of touch
magazine
publisher on the nbc sitcom just shoot
me
which ran for seven seasons and earned
him two golden globe nominations
oh i told you to stop playing with that
thing ah it doesn't work anyway see
god it does work then in 2013
siegel was cast in abc's the goldbergs
playing albert
the affable grandfather look at this
billy jones coming to town you got to
see this
look at this picture of him
he's wearing the exact same sunglasses
as i
am oh yeah the show is currently airing
in its eighth season
siegel's final episode will air april
7th
it's just funny stuff i don't know why
but people yelling at each other
are pissed all the time at one another
it's really funny
funny stuff abc entertainment and the
goldberg's creator
adam f goldberg both released statements
praising siegel
calling out the indelible mark and
amazing legacy he's left on hollywood
there's a light on and there's a guy
with a camera and people are going gonna
see this well
that was really exciting to me back in
high school will you can you imagine now
when this is gonna be on television
siegel is survived by his wife sonia
as well as his two daughters paulie and
elizabeth
[Music]
you